also I had left my mom's house not
because of anything other than the fact
that it was a toxic environment and it
was not good for my mental
health brothers and sisters please
donate as we have come together one umah
to get the necessary Aid needed to
Palestine and Gaza donate now inah
whatever you can and allow us to reach
the aid with one umah to our brothers
and sisters in Palestine one day
Palestine will be free asalam Alum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
when it comes to issues like this
pertaining to individuals their family
members Etc it's not something that I
like to get into it's nothing to do with
me it doesn't concern me and I try to
stay away from stuff like that but when
I see a reoccurring pattern of
ungrateful kids ungrateful children
especially towards their parents in
today's time like the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him said a day would come
where the woman the mother will be
giving birth to her slave master some of
the scholars understood this as that
she'll be giving birth to a child who be
telling her what to do you know he'll be
bossing her around like a slave so we
see this in current times alhamdulillah
the prophet P spoke the h today I'm
going to share with you guys inshallah
what's going on with our sister modish
Street I think that's what she's called
uh we're going to be talking about
inshallah her daughter who's left the
house now why am I talking about this
I'm talking about this because I want
this to be a lesson for everyone for
that matter it's not pertaining to these
individuals anytime I speak about a
specific individual I'm actually talking
to a wider audience I'm talking to
thousands if not millions of people who
are going to go through this this can be
something that affects my house yes this
can be something that affects your house
this something that affects our children
and you watching this Who as a young
individual this will affect you and you
should watch this very very carefully
and listen Okay so we're going get
straight into it yeah this came out in
public I don't know if the girl the her
daughter came out publicly or vice versa
my wife saw this yeah I don't know
nothing about it my wife sorry and said
look did you hear about this Etc she was
a bit disturbed as well she was like you
know it's sad it's sad to see these
things happen and for it to go public
it's even more sad however I'm going to
come and touch on a few stuff and I'm
going to get straight into what the
cause of the problem I believe is
generally not specifically to this this
family and that what are the rights of a
mother and father specifically a mother
in this instant let's first hear the
recording of her daughter yeah yeah I'm
going to blur her face the reason I'm
going to blur her face is number one
again just her identity number two
because she's just got too much makeup
she's 17 years old you're 17 years old
and you've got eyelashes you've got so
much makeup going on okay okay Etc so I
I'm just going to uh blur that inshallah
but let's just watch and hear for
ourself hi I've tried keeping this off
of social media for like the past seven
months but now it's completely getting
out of hand so as you guys may know my
mom has publicly addressed me on social
media a few times and I just want to
start off by saying I don't want to
slander my mom in any way matter of fact
I don't want any form of Scandal because
I just hate being problematic and I just
wish it never came to this obviously I
never wanted to make this video but
because so many rumors have surfaced
online I just felt as though I needed to
say my part online my mom mentioned a
sum of £
5,940 no I didn't steal it from her I
worked to get that money and it was
later than taken out of my account by
her and her husband over the past couple
of weeks I've been attempting to get in
contact with her privately um literally
just requesting for that doesn't make
any sense sorry I'm not I'm not with it
right now um I basically contacted her
just politely requesting for my money
back my mom however responded online for
thousands of people to see which I think
is completely unnecessary yesterday when
I messaged her pretty much asking how my
siblings were and whether or not she had
even seen my previous messages I was
then pretty much sworn out and was told
to get lost and that's when I said have
a nice life and keep making taah for me
I think what I said was completely taken
out of context and what I meant by that
message was me not genuinely
understanding how she can go to umra
make taah for me but then post it to
social media whereas she could have
literally just reached out to me to tell
me that she may her off for me or to
like ask me how things are do you know
what I mean I didn't in any way mean to
come across as though I was
disrespecting tawa I was just shocked
because she was mean to me on text but
when it came to her going to om she post
red love heart do you know what I mean
also I had left my mom's house not
because of anything other than the fact
that it was a toxic environment and it
was not good for my health I don't want
to get into too much detail but no I
didn't leave to be with some guy I left
for the sake of my sanity and my wellbe
anyways guys I'm going to leave it here
I am so tired it's 5:00 a.m. now and
obviously wedding season and that if you
know you know anyways take care of
yourselves guys so now guys I'm going to
get straight into it we were talking
about taah okay I'm going to touch up on
this okay in a way where we really need
to understand there is great amount of
disrespect happening towards our parent
by Immature childish uh entitled spoiled
brat now I'm not referring to her I'm
saying in general that's what's
happening but talking about taah and
that your mom did ta for you yeah you
should thank Allah subhana wa tala my
sister I don't know what your name is
that your mother yes your mother has
gone to TA and doing t for you and it's
clearly evidence from the Quran andah
that you can do this the fact that she's
doing that for you number two it reminds
me of an incident of Abdullah Omar he
saw once talking about ta yeah he saw a
man carrying his mother on his shoulders
or in his hands he was carrying her
because she was old and he was doing
taah and once he finished ta he came to
abdah Omar and he asked this very simple
question did I pay back my mom for what
she has done for me do you know what
abdah said he said you did not pay her
back for the one of she said when she
was given birth to you I repeat again
you did not pay her back you know ta
that you done seven times carrying her
it was really hard yeah you did not pay
her back probably for one off she said
in pain when she's given birth to you
how could anyone for that matter I'm
going to go with a default position
let's suppose your mother is a very very
evil person which I doubt she is okay
and I just want to make something clear
I have no affiliation with the sister I
do not know her so I don't want to come
across I'm just defending I'm defending
the truth I'm defending whoever it is
for that matter for the sake of Allah I
don't agree with everything the sister
does I don't know much about her anyways
just cut into the chase you need to
understand something my dear sister
you're 17 years old I have to blow your
face because you're Caked Up you've got
eyelashes they are quite big you're
seeing you was doing this video 5: in
the morning you're doing it 5: in the
morning why have you got so much makeup
on 5: in the morning look at your nails
look at eyelashes now before somebody
feminist getting a tantrum and she can
do she likes ripping your hair out you
can rip your hair out go to Turkey and
get hair transplant okay I do not care
about anyone in their opinions okay 17
years old and the way you're dressed Etc
blah BL this is why it's so so important
brothers and sisters very very vital and
once again I want to give a disclaimer
I'm not seeing no one our sister didn't
do a good parenting Etc she's made her
own side where she talks about putting
boundaries in place and in today's age
when there's boundaries in place it is
classed as toxicity yes it's this this
toxic energy or whatever you want to
call it for that matter today kids label
labels are used yeah the word narcissism
I've heard the word narcism from Left
Right Center everyone's a narcissist
yeah toxic toxic negative energy or
toxic energy Etc what's toxic energy
these days oh when Mom comes and tells
you don't do this don't hang around with
those people they're not good for you
don't hang around with them they're not
good for you warning you trying to guide
you your mother wants the best for you
okay and I'm going to go through a few
evidences where the Quran and Sunnah
Allah tells us in the Quran that after
you worship Him you do not even say off
to your mom your parents you don't say
off to them yeah let me tell you
something my dear sister do not ever
ever think that you will ever have
prosperity in your life if your mom and
your father or your father displeased
with you specially your mother if they
are displeased with
you I swear upon the of the that your
mom you will never see any prosperity
and I'm telling you from an experience
that I know of people whose lives are
ruined till this day because they would
insult their mother the prophet Muhammad
said may his face be rubbed in dust may
his face be rubbed in dust may his face
be robbed in dust for the parent for a
child whose parent reach old age and it
doesn't look after
if we cannot today no matter what your
mom has done unless she's put put your
life in danger or some kind of which I
highly doubt okay she is your mother
okay no matter what happens for you to
leave home for you to leave home look
you live in the UK you can do whatever
you like but for you to leave home it's
a disrespect to your mother and for your
mom who from her side of the story again
okay for her to say that she's been
saving up for you with her money her W
that she's been doing it for you and
your well-being I would say you're 17y
old you are making the biggest mistake
in your life okay you making making the
biggest mistake in your life and you
will come to that realization and let me
tell you my dear young sister your
friends around you none of them care
about you none of them care about you
trust me I know I've been young I've
been with friends who I would fight for
who have got done all kind of Madness
for and when the day came one day I got
jumed none of my friends were there your
friends will not be there for you the
ones who truly love you is your mother
your father your siblings okay amongst
all of them it's Allah subhana wa tala
Allah subhana and the prophet mammed
peace be upon him put them first I want
to recommend a book to you called Beauty
sick the reason I'm saying this is
because the fact that I see your nails I
see your eyelashes I see the way your
makeup and it's 5: in the morning it's
the sickness of beauty okay my dear
sister you are a Muslim woman okay I
honor you like my younger sister like my
daughter okay I'm telling you something
listen to your mom return back to your
house this is just a request it's not a
legal thing no proceedings in place
apologize I would say go and kiss your
mother's feet W let me tell you
something before Islam I used to be very
harsh to my mom I used to be very rude
to my mom I never listened to my mom W
when I came to Islam W when I came came
to Islam and my mother knows W I came to
my realization Society made me something
I wasn't I didn't respect my mom my mom
had endless nights worrying where I am
am I dead am I alive so much worries W I
regret those till this day and I do
everything in my power to serve my
mother and I'm still not a good son and
I'm still not good of a son I'm telling
you as a individual maybe could be old
enough to be your father Yes I think I'm
old enough to be your father if I had
kid at 17 yes you she'll be 17 years old
but the point is this go back to your
mom and be say I'm sorry
ask her forgiveness yes this is my
recommendation to you okay but please W
I'm telling you Allah subhana man one of
the said when his mother died he cried
he said my doors to Jen have been closed
W you will never ever get a mother
nobody will ever replace your mother and
W something my mom would say to me she
would say to me the day you have kids
you would say to me you my mom will say
that I will tell her oh Mom you have not
loved me enough meaning that your your
love to your own kids will be so great
you will think that you would expect
your mom to love you more if that makes
sense yeah so the point is what you will
never get another mother yes and obey
your mom there's many Quran Hadith ay in
this like we know the prophet Muhammad
PE upon AB a man came and said who has
more right over me he said your mother
then who he said your mother then who he
said your mother then who he said then
your father then your father Yes this
doesn't mean respect our fathers read
the book you might not know basic
principles etiquette how to treat your
parents your father your mother W if you
want blessings I speak to everyone
anybody that wants blessings and
prosperity in your life if you disobey
your parents if you make your parents
upset W I'm telling you your life will
be in misery you will not see any Bara
in your life and I'll end on this so
much so the prophet P even said a form
of jihad is what's serving your parents
there was a man who came to offensive
Jihad and he said I left my parents weep
in to come and join the course he said
go back and make them happy and smile
just the way you made them cry yes go
back and there are many many Hadi your
mother looked after you yes your mother
carried you she had endless sleepless
nights to look after you she suckled you
yes when you was helpless she had to
change your nappies and you today have
grown and all of a sudden Miss
Independent and all of a sudden you
might see there's an attack I'm saying
this cuz I care about you my sister I
say this cuz I care about you my sister
okay I have no affiliation with your
mother I do not know I've I've met her
her and her brother once yes other than
that is my witness I do not expect
anything from her nothing I'm not doing
this video for nothing but that it hurts
me to see this video and my wife showed
it w my wife even said to me can you
imagine maybe our daughters that grow up
one day this might happen to us and W it
can that's why Allah says he will test
us with our children was tested with his
own son yes and guidance is from Allah
subhana wa tala brothers and sisters
anytime this order happens in your house
look internally what sins are you
committing what R are you involved in
what major sins who did you oppress W
let me tell you something it is these
things that generally is a reason why we
see disorder sometimes it's a test
sometimes Alam can we blame Alam no it
was a test so I ask Allah subhana T to
make it easy on the sister with his
daughter with her daughter and I ask ask
our young sister who is going through
this W do not make this mistake honor
your mother and your father both of them
yes and the day will come where you will
regret what you're doing and I ask you
gently and kindly return back to your
house apologize to your mother and
accept that she has boundaries and there
should be boundaries my dear mothers
parents who are watching this fix your
children at a young age because if you
don't and once again disclaimer I'm not
accusing anybody of not doing that I'm
just saying generally if we do not
install the dean and the love of Allah
subhana wa tala and the Quran in our
children do not be surprised when they
grow up they go astray and this can
happen to households which already do
them unseen try your best make Dua ask
Allah when you see things going wrong
ask what mistakes have you done that has
caused these things to happen in your
house okay these things happen and again
it can be that a mother or a father who
have raised their children upright but
they have gone astray like Noam and his
his son many examples in history but
generally let's focus on this otherwise
we are going to lose our kids to the
system and they are going to go and
follow this and that and destroy their
life W that's all I have to say sorry
for blooding on but at the end of the
day this is something that I really
really touched me uh and I really hope
that this affair is resolved insh and
may Allah subh make it easy on them
anything I said wrong is for myself and
Shan anything good from is from Allah
and his messenger uh to my young sister
I am sorry if I come AC passionate I'm
not going to go at you but genuinely
care about you please please please I
urge you go and speak to your mom um
delete these videos Etc and if that
happens this just a video of reminder
well if need I will delete this video as
well but in nutsh show I'm doing this
because I want the wider audience to
understand this and I ask you guys to
fear Allah subh T in backbiting and
accusing things of she left the house
because of of a guy Etc fear Allah this
is the honor of another woman this is
slander this is a major
sin
Islam net is establishing a Masjid and a
community center if you donate to build
this Masjid Allah will in build a house
for you in Jenna with bricks of gold and
silver every person who prays in this
Masjid every child that memorize the
Quran you will insh shareing that reward
donate now guys and do not
[Music]
delay